tonight's it on your side made your life
changes ever-changing tax laws make
finding a trustworthy tax preparer very
important we've got eight tips to help
you choose the right one
the first thing I always tell people is
you need to evaluate what you need
Henderson resident Derek colada has been
doing taxes for almost three decades he
says once you determine how complicated
your tax needs are get a referral for a
tax preparer from family or friends
review those credentials when you get
the person's name Google their email
address
right look them up on p10.org it's a
website and believe it or not on the IRS
website you can also look up a person's
credentials EA CPAs and tax attorneys
all qualify to represent their clients
meet with your preparer see if you get
along consider their availability are
they seasonal or full time if the IRS
finds errors on your tax forms or
decides to perform an audit choose a tax
preparer who is available to help you
year round the BBB says the following is
a red flag now just be wary of large tax
returns that are promised especially if
they are larger than say what a
competitor had promised you before you
agree to any Services read the contracts
carefully understand how much the tax
preparer charges for the services and
last but not least does your preparer
have ethics okay are they willing to say
no I'm not going to do that I want to
test them a little bit on that and see
yeah and see if they do because if
they'll stand up to you that means
they're doing it their job
in addition to p10.org and the IRS
website the BBB can always guide you to
verify if a business is properly
licensed as well just head to bbb.org
all tax tips